merci on appelle Savary de nouvelles
compagnie pendant cette première
demi-heure sénateur LR de la Marne
rapporteur de la branche US et membre de
cette commission mixte paritaire qui
s'est réuni hier d'abord comment ça
s'est passé ça a duré près de 9h quel
était l'ambiance oui effectivement il y
a eu des discussions on a refait un
débat constructif car
c'est conclu par effectivement
un
apport de chacune des chambres
les députés ont été empêchés de voter
par un débattre très obstructures non
plus non pas pu débattre n'ont pas pu
voter il était important qu'il puisse se
retrouver si on veut qu'il vote c'est
très fort mais ils ont amené un certain
nombre de choses notamment notamment par
rapport au bord d'un dash le carrière
longue ils ont amené la durée de 43 ans
pour chaque borne ils ont amené une
clause de revoyure et le Sénat
parallèlement avait travaillé déjà
depuis longue date puisque c'est la
réforme qui avait été proposée par le
Sénat avec la prise en compte notamment
de l'usure professionnelle prise en
compte des difficultés des mères de
famille pris en compte de l'afrod qu'il
faut combattre par rapport à ce système
là donc c'est un compromis de l'ensemble
des des parlementaires on va revenir
longuement sur les détails du texte et
vous nous expliquerez plusieurs points
mais on a vu que la gauche était assez
énervé par le fait que cette CMP n'était
pas publique alors ce qui est de
tradition que les CMP se déroulent avec
eux mais est-ce que du coup ça a tendu
l'ambiance est-ce que l'ambiance était
tendue pendant ces années mais c'est pas
parce que il y a des fossil féations
qu'on va se plier quand même c'est il
faut être tout à fait attentif on peut
pas
empêcher le débat
de l'Assemblée nationale empêcher la
commission mixte paritaire de délibérer
il y a un moment quand même la
démocratie c'est la démocratie il faut
quand même faire en sorte de la
démocratie non il y avait pas une remise
en cause mais on voit bien que il y
avait une volonté
parfois de faire traîner les choses mais
parfois également de rentrer dans le
débat donc il y a eu un vrai débat il y
a eu un ami il y a même un amendement
qui a été pris et Manon de la gauche ce
qui concerne les femmes et les prises en
compte de trimestre de majoration donc
on voit bien que c'était ouvert et ce
qu'on voulait participer ont pu y
participer et tout le monde y a
participé
globalement tout le monde y a participé
quoi qu'on dise il y a eu un vrai débat
une vraie avancée et c'est une
conclusion tout à fait ouverte aux
divers ou divers formation politique
alors bien sûr il y a les postures il y
a les postures ceux qui sont opposés et
ils ont le droit d'être opposé mais ceux
qui sont favorables ont le droit d'être
favorables et c'est pour ça qu'il était
important qu'on puisse avoir des débats
contradictoires qui conduisent
véritablement à une synthèse je voudrais
vous faire réagir à une déclaration de
Monique ruban c'est votre collègue
sénatrice socialiste elle aussi membre
de cette commission mixparitaire et chef
de fil du Parti socialiste sur ce texte
quand on est arrivé ce matin tout était
fait mais bon ça n'est pas étonnant en
même temps alors nous nous avons repassé
tous les articles évidemment mais tout
était fait bien sûr une CMP c'est comme
ça mais il faut surtout pas faire croire
aux gens qu'il y avait encore des marges
de manœuvre en CMP aujourd'hui tout
était réglé voilà c'est un arrangement
entre la droite et la droite quoi on
fait voilà la droite
macroniste démontre qu'elle est de
droite au cas où on n'aurait pas encore
compris et la droite des républicains
s'accorde parfaitement avec la droite
macroniste et tout ça ça fait un projet
de droite à la raison tout était déjà
calé avant c'est le principe du CMP où
je peux vous dire qu'effectivement nous
avons trouvé avec un rapporteur général
de l'Assemblée nationale des accords ça
a duré même la nuit pour faire en sorte
que on puisse avoir vous savez c'est ça
le fruit d'un compromis c'est dire voilà
moi j'ai ça ça voilà et en conséquence
là on a trouvé un compromis entre les
députés et notamment les députés LR
entre la majorité sénatoriale et la
proposition de la majorité
présidentielle c'est la raison pour
laquelle on arrive avec un texte on va
pas arriver de la CMP les mains dans les
poches et puis commencer à refaire un
débat le débat il a eu lieu il a été
empêché à l'Assemblée nationale c'est là
où il y a le vrai problème au Sénat on a
pu malgré les tentatives d'obstruction
arriver au débat et au vote et en
conséquence la CMP n'avait plus qu'à
faire en sorte de prendre en compte
toutes les propositions qui a été
formulées de part et d'autre des
discussions qui ont été apres il y a des
points où les discussions vraiment
étaient absents et avec qui oui oui oui
parce que il y a notamment venant de la
nups toujours les volontés de de grandes
déclarations dont la portée n'est pas
forcément tout à fait évidente quant à
l'avancée du débat et puis de l'autre
côté il y a quand même ceux qui mettent
les poils sur les i et puis qui
répondent aux questions moi j'ai répondu
pendant 8 heures aux questions qui m'a
été posées aucun des parlementaires qui
étaient dans cette CMP ne peut dire
qu'il n'a pas eu réponse à ces questions
et en conséquence nous avons choisi les
textes ensuite et voter et le vote c'est
véritablement le vote
la démocratique qui fait qu'on arrive à
un texte qui me semble prendre en compte
les difficultés largement exposées par
les Français on va rentrer dans le
détail du texte est-ce que le texte
c'est exactement celui que vous vouliez
ou est-ce que vous avez vous aussi
accepté des mesures par compromis oui on
a modifié on a recadré nos mesures et
tant mieux vous voyez par exemple pour
le CDI senior on a eu une avancée
importante quand même l'accord national
interprofessionnel sur l'emploi des
seniors de en chômage en demandeur
d'emploi de longue durée pardon sera
pris en compte ça c'est une avancée et
parallèlement on fera le CDI senior vous
voyez sur l'incapacité permanente oui on
a appris en compte il y aura une
retraite anticipée pour ceux qui sont
particulièrement exposés et qui ont un
taux d'incapacité plus de 20% donc ils
ont été usés et bien ces personnes dès
60 ans pourront en partir à la retraite
je voudrais dire surtout que par rapport
à cet âge légal des 64 ans il y a des
dispositifs dérogatoires pour prendre en
compte justement les difficultés de
différents métiers et en fait il va y
avoir 5 assis que personne seulement qui
vont être touchées par les 64 ans il y
en a quatre à cinq qui ne seront pas
touchés par la borne des 64 ans et même
plus que ça dans le calcul qui pourront
partir avant et dans le calcul nous
sommes sur un système par deux piliers
donc il y a le pilier de la durée de
cotisation 43 ans certains peuvent quand
ils commencent à toucher par la durée et
puis quand vous commencez plus tard et
ben c'est la borne d'âge qui vous
protège pour que vous travaillez pas
plus longtemps c'est pour ça que nous
avons choisi cette solution me
semble-t-il la plus adaptée ou aux
répartie l'effort collectif que vous
commenciez tôt que vous commenciez tard
avec des dérogations pour ceux qui sont
particulièrement usés et qui font qu'on
équilibre un système en maintenant un
niveau de pension relatif quand même
correct par rapport au niveau moyen
parce que sinon c'est une dégradation
complète dans les années qui viennent
avec non seulement un déficit de plus de
10 milliards par an cumulés ça fait
quand même des sommes importantes et
également un niveau de retraite des des
pensionnés qui diminueraient voilà
pourquoi nous sommes attachés c'est très
forme de font et justement on va rentrer
dans le détail du texte quel texte
précisément est sorti de cette
commission mixparitaire et sera donc
soumis au vote du Parlement aujourd'hui
on fait le point avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Audrey
[Musique]
la Commission mixparitaire a donc été
conclusive hier à quoi ressemble le
texte sur lequel se sont mis d'accord
députés et sénateurs alors d'abord faut
commencer par le point névralgique le
cœur même de la réforme à savoir
l'article 7 qui consacre le report de
l'âge légal à la retraite de 62 à 64 ans
il a donc été adopté bon sans grande
surprise parce que parmi les 14
parlementaires qui composaient cette
commission mixte paritaire vous en
faisiez partie il y en avait 10 qui
étaient en faveur de cette mesure on va
peut-être pouvoir le regarder sur une
infographie vous avez donc en jaune et
en orange qui vont apparaître voilà donc
ça c'est la majorité présidentielle et
puis en bleu clair ce sont les
républicains René Paul Savary j'imagine
que c'est une satisfaction pour vous
ouais écoutez ça fait 4 ans qu'on
propose cela et en conséquence nous
pensons intimement et que cette réforme
même si elle est difficilement acceptée
et acceptable elle sera à terme bonne
pour l'équilibre de notre système de
retraite parce que on continue à avoir
une durée de retraite de plus en plus
longue avoir une natalité qui baisse de
moins en moins de cotisants mais
qu'est-ce que vous voulez si nous vous
prenions passer mesures ça veut dire que
nos successeurs vont travailler jusqu'au
65 ans et ça va pas être 43 ans de durée
de cotisation mais 45 ans moi je
l'accepte pas c'est pour ça que je dis
prenons nos responsabilités il y va de
l'importance de l'équilibre de système
c'est à la génération actuelle de faire
en sorte de proposer l'équilibre mais il
y a vous avez entendu la gauche qui vous
l'a peut-être dit hier en CMP il y avait
d'autres moyens d'aboutir à cet
équilibre oui la gauche un autre
dispositif les impôts ou la dette mais
ça va à l'encontre d'un système de
répartition c'est la contribution qui
anime un système par répartition et
c'est vrai qu'on a eu des débats avec
une confrontation de projets différents
entre la droite et la gauche moi je suis
satisfait de voir qu'on retrouve un peu
des des valeurs différentes on a le
droit de penser différemment mais on a
le droit surtout de penser à nos enfants
et si on équilibre pas ce système de
retraite ça veut dire qu'on fait des
pensions à crédit c'est pas concevable
dans un esprit qu'on puisse bénéficier
de pension qu'il soit payé par les
successeurs c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut revenir à la réalité
des choses il y a quelque chose qu'on
oublie trop fréquemment c'est que nous
avons obtenu nous les formations de
droite du gouvernement qu'il y ait une
revalorisation des petits pensions pour
les retraités qui étaient déjà à la
retraite on est déjà oublié mais si nous
avions pas eu cette démarche et bien
elle est retraités n'auraient pas eu une
augmentation alors pas forcément pour
aller
mais une petite augmentation pour des
petites retraites c'est toujours
significatif nous avons passé à ces
personnes là en difficulté et nous avons
pensé à travers les mesures du Sénat aux
personnes qui sont usées quand vous
travaillez 10 fils dans des métiers durs
que vous êtes dans des Forges des choses
comme ça on va pas les porter jusque 64
ans ces personnes-là elles sont usées
avant c'est pour ça qu'elle il est
nécessaire d'avoir des dispositifs que
les personnes qui connaissent des
métiers difficiles est un agent anticipé
de façon à ce que leur durée de retraite
soit pris par anticipation pour qu'ils
aient également droit à une retraite de
la même durée que ceux qui soient un peu
moins usé qui peuvent le prendre plus
tardivement Audrey quels sont les autres
dispositions importantes à adopter hier
alors il y en a beaucoup qui viennent du
Sénat évidemment puisque le texte a été
voté au Sénat et pas à l'Assemblée
d'abord la surcote jusqu'à 5% pour les
maires de famille qui ont une carrière
complète à 63 ans et qui continuerait
jusqu'à 64 ans ça c'était une ligne
rouge du président de la républicain
Bruno Retailleau à noter qu'en ce qui
concerne les maires de famille deux
amendements portés par la sénatrice
socialiste Laurence Rossignol sont
gardés ils garantissent au maire de
bénéficier de certains trimestres liés à
l'éducation de leur enfant et puis il y
a le CDI senior ça aussi c'est important
pour vous exonéré de cotisations
familiales autres rapports du Sénat qui
sera d'abord discuté avec les
partenaires sociaux et puis si jamais on
n'arrive pas à un accord il pourra faire
l'objet d'une expérimentation jusqu'en
2026 ça concernera les chômeurs de
longue durée de plus de 60 ans vous êtes
satisfait il y a beaucoup d'apports du
Sénat finalement dans cette commission
où on avait imaginez quelque chose et il
fallait remettre les partenaires sociaux
nous le souhaitions et nous avons trouvé
une une formulation qui doit convenir à
tout le monde parce qu'on les remet au
coeur du dispositif par le biais d'un
accord
national interprofessionnel si on ne
fait pas une vraie politique pour
l'employabilité des seniors on échouera
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons une grande stratégie nationale
un senior une solution qui doit être
déclinée chacun à son niveau et si les
partenaires sociaux ne s'emparent pas
effectivement de ce thème là et bien ce
sera difficile de sortir les seniors qui
sont actuellement au chômage du chômage
et la meilleure solution qu'on puisse
leur proposer c'est pas d'être dans une
dans la précarité c'est pas d'être en
fin de carrière dans la cage chômage
c'est véritablement de pouvoir à travers
notamment un CDI seniors avoir un emploi
adapté à ces difficultés et on va jusque
dans ce cadre-là on va jusqu'au taux
plein de la personne on l'apporte on la
laissant un emploi et en incitant
l'employeur à la Gard jusqu'au taux
plein c'est à dire au moment où elle
pourra liquider sa retraite avoir une
retraite cruelle ou l'âge d'annulation
de la décote pour ceux qui sont un peu
plus tardif mais sûrement pas jusque 70
ans comme dans le dispositif actuel donc
là-dessus je pense sur une avancée que
le CDI senior doit pouvoir rendre
service et maintenir des seigneurs en
emploi il y a un autre point sur lequel
vous allez travailler vous en parler un
peu tout à l'heure c'est la question de
la retraite progressive est-ce que là la
CMP est allée assez loin alors la CMP
n'est pas été aussi loin que j'aurais
souhaité sur la retraite progressive
pourquoi parce qu'elle est portée deux
ans avant l'âge légal donc à partir de
62 ans j'aurais préféré l'apporter un
peu avant mais ça posait des difficultés
parce que c'est indispensive ne veut
voilà je voulais la garder à partir de
60 ans notamment pour les salariés du
privé mais on est arrivé à un système si
vous voulez ou contenu que c'est un une
épure budgétaire il s'agit d'arriver à
laquelle libre quand il s'agit de
combler les déficits il s'agit pas de
les accentuer et en conséquence on
arrive à un système qui devenait
illisible c'est la raison pour laquelle
on
ça va être trop compliqué illisible
c'est pas la peine le système de
retraite est déjà suffisamment compliqué
donc effectivement on restera deux ans
avant l'âge légal donc à partir de 62
ans mais ouvert à toutes les professions
c'était réservé aux salariés là
maintenant c'est aussi pour les
indépendants les professions libérales
mais également les fonctionnaires c'est
pour ça qu'il faut bien un cadrer le
dispositif il y a un autre point Audrey
en a parlé c'est la surcote pour les
mères de famille ça c'est une ligne
rouge des républicains au Sénat ça a été
gardé dans le texte final mais est-ce
que quand même les femmes restent
pénalisées par cette réforme notamment
sur la question des trimestres maternité
les femmes restent effectivement à
connaître les difficultés qu'elle les
différences les inégalités qu'il y a à
travers les salaires il y a des
différences de salaire du fait des
carrières hachées des mères de famille
qui font parallèlement à la fois
l'éducation de leur enfant et qui
continuent leur carrière mais souvent la
carrière est hachée donc effectivement
il y a des différences de rémunération
elle se traduisent au niveau des
retraites automatiquement puisque c'est
un système distributifs elles sont
atténuées au niveau des retraites mais
nous avons pensé qu'il fallait aller
plus loin parce qu'on demande quand même
aussi à ces femmes de continuer un petit
peu à travailler et en conséquence nous
avons adapté le dispositif de surcote
pour que la mère de famille notamment
parce qu'elle a des majorations de
trimestres liées au maternité ou liées à
l'éducation suit soit à travers ce
dispositif
à avoir une pension plus élevée contenue
du fait qu'on lui demande de travailler
un petit peu plus longtemps pour pouvoir
aller jusque 5%. c'est quand même une
façon de réduire la différence de
pension qu'il y a entre les hommes et
les femmes et la volonté c'est vraiment
d'arriver à terme à l'égalité mais on
sait que le terme est loin on arrivera à
l'égalité pratiquement qu'en 2070 donc
il est important de prendre des mesures
avant d'ailleurs on a on a remis dans la
loi un rapport là-dessus pour étudier
effectivement cette volonté d'égalité de
de pension entre les hommes et les
femmes on y contribue alors modestement
modestement faut le reconnaître on peut
toujours faire plus mais après faut voir
que les avantages que l'on peut donner
faut qu'il soit répartis et le plus
justement possible que ce soit pas au
détriment d'autres parce que derrière il
y a un équilibre il y a un dispositif
sur les carrières longues aussi qui a
créé plusieurs quiproquoyèrent oui parce
que dans un premier temps les rumeurs
disaient que l'amendement d'Aurélien
Pradier le député LR du Lot serait
retenu bah oui parce que vous étiez dans
le secret du huis clos alors nous on
essayait d'avoir des petites infos vous
savez il voulait que toutes les
personnes qui ont commencé à travailler
avant 21 ans même dans les contrats
d'été puissent partir après 43 annuités
finalement la commission mixte paritaire
a choisi de garder un autre amendement
celui du président des députés LR
Olivier marlex écoutez
l'amendement Pradier est un abonnement
très très coûteux parce qu'il disait il
suffit d'un trimestre par exemple un
stage d'été pour vous faire rentrer en
carrière longue non non on est resté sur
ce qui est une vraie carrière longue ce
qui est beaucoup moins coûteux qui
correspond plus à l'amendement que
soutenait Olivier Marley sous d'autres
l'amendement retenu concerne donc celles
et ceux qui peuvent prétendre au
dispositifs carrière longue quand ils
ont commencé à travailler avant 21 ans
ils peuvent partir après 43 années
évidemment si et seulement si ils ont
cotisé le nombre de trimestres
nécessaires 4 ou 5 et si ils ont atteint
l'âge de départ anticipé auquel ils ont
droit encore des concessions au LR
peut-être mais c'est une réflexion
largement partagée si vous voulez il y
avait quand même une anomalie mais qui
est issue de la réforme Touraine ne
l'oublions pas sont les conséquences
quand même de cette réforme votée par la
gauche parce que quelquefois il
semblerait l'oublier la durée de
cotisation à 43 ans c'est bien la
réforme Touraine et quand vous
l'appliquez dans le cas de la réforme
Toine aujourd'hui dans la loi
quand vous partez à 16 ans vous avez une
durée de cotisation de la durée acquise
plus deux ans c'est-à-dire 45 ans avec
l'amendement que nous avons pris ce sera
43 ans c'est important de le dire mais
ça veut dire que c'est la durée de
cotisation plancher c'est l'âge c'est la
durée minimum de cotisation et les 43
ans de même que le départ de l'âge légal
à 62 60 c'est l'âge minimum légal si
vous avez vos cotisations quand vous
arrivez à 63 ans vous avez vos 43 ans de
cotisations vous n'avez que 63 ans faut
travailler jusque 64 d'accord il faut
bien attendre l'âge légal donc vous
travaillez 44 ans au niveau des jeunes
il était proposé dès le départ il est
inscrit actuellement dans la loi que
ceux qui partent à 16 ans ou à 18 ans
allaient travailler 44 ans l'amendement
qui a été pris c'est que on ne mettra
pas plus de 43 ans dans la demande on
mettra les 43 ans à chacune des bornes
celui qui a 43 ans il arrive avec son
taux plein mais s'il est pas la borne un
gilet comme tout le monde il faut qu'il
atteigne un port de DASH c'est pour ça
qu'il y en a qui effectivement peuvent
travailler un petit peu plus comme c'est
une montée en charge il peut y avoir des
trimestres supplémentaires des Français
qui sont dans un dispositif de carrière
longue et qui ont lancé 162 trimestres
pourront quand même travailler plus de
quoi rendre 3 ans s'ils n'ont pas leur
172 trimestres à la borne à 58 69 bien
sûr on va pas les empêcher du jour au
lendemain quand vous avez votre taux
plein avant l'âge légal bah vous
continuez à travailler donc vous arrivez
de personnes vont être avantagés par
rapport à ce qui est proposé attendez on
leur imposait 44 ans de de cotisation là
on leur impose pour avoir le taux plein
que 43 ans c'est quand même une avancée
mais ce qu'il faut bien retenir c'est
que dans notre système de retraite c'est
une durée minimale de de
cotisations il faut avoir au moins 43
ans pour avoir le taux plein il faut
avoir au moins l'âge légal 62 ans
aujourd'hui ou 64 ans demain pour
pouvoir rentrer en retraite vous avez
les deux critères donc automatiquement
vous avez des gens qui commencent tôt
celui qui commence à 20 ans il a 43 ans
il arrive à 63 ans il a ses trimestres
mais il peut pas prendre sa retraite
puisque c'est 64 donc il aura bien 44
ans de travail aujourd'hui c'est déjà
comme ça il vous faut 42 ans quand vous
commencez jeune vous arrivez à 61 ans
vous avez dans le système aujourd'hui
vaut 42 ans de cotisations et vous
arrivez à 61 ans mais il faut bien
travailler jusque 62 et cette personne
qui a commencé jeune et ben elle aura 44
ans de 43 ans de cotisation donc c'est
le même système ce sont des planchers
c'est ce qu'il faut bien expliquer et
quand vous mettez ce plancher au borne
d'âge de ceux qui ont commencé le
bonheur 16 18 20 21 ans et ben ce que
l'on exige pour le thé plat c'est 43 ans
de cotisations contre 44 et 45 ans qui
était auparavant exigé dans la loi j'ai
été clair on comprend pas la différence
non parce que jusqu'à jusqu'à hier matin
par exemple quelqu'un qui avait commencé
à travailler à 16 ans
il devait aller jusqu'à il devait
cotiser jusqu'à 60 ans ça limite d'âge
c'est 60 ans aujourd'hui le 16 ans le 16
ans qu'à 4 à Sainte trimestre avant la
fin de l'année de ses exemples on lui
propose une date plus de c'est-à-dire
qui travaille 45 ans voilà pour partir à
58 donc vous voyez bien quelque part que
il est touché par la borne d'âge avant
d'être le truc demain on lui mettra que
43 ans de durer voilà la durée minimum
pour partir à 16 ans ce sera 43 ans avec
la bande de 58 ans et non pas plus voilà
il y en a qui selon les âges pourront
continuer ou pas et elle n'apporte etc
mais ce qui est important c'est que
cette durée minimum de cotisation soit
de 43 ans quel que soit le moment où
vous travaillez c'est ce qu'il faut
retenir et qu'il y aura toujours selon
aussi ou selon ça selon vos carrières
des possibilités effectivement d'avoir
un moment un travail plus long mais par
contre vous prenez quelqu'un qui est
pendant un an fait un déplacement à
l'étranger il a aucune cotisation il a
commencé jeune bon lui demande que 43 on
lui demande pas 44 donc il peut avoir le
top là à partir du moment où il aura
l'âge minimum légal de départ en
retraite donc c'est un système qui est
plus égalitaire qu'il n'était parce
qu'il était inégalité il y a une partie
des inégalités qui sont gommées pas
toutes les inégalités si nous avions
gommé toutes les inégalités ont tombé
dans un autre système mais ça coûtait un
milliard deux à 9 milliards d'euros ce
serait le système on disait plus bornage
on met 43 ans pour tout le monde sauf
que si on veut équilibrer notre système
de réparer pas c'est pas 43 ans c'est 45
ans pour tout le monde est-ce que les
Français veulent qu'on leur met 45 ans
de durée de cotisations non c'est pour
ça que nous disons faut jouer sur les
deux piliers mais c'est complexe et je
comprends que les dis les Français du
mal à comprendre il faut vraiment être à
l'intérieur et beaucoup n'ont pas
compris ne te la larchitecture de de ces
systèmes de retraite nous avons gommé un
certain nombre d'égalité pas tout est
inégalités parce que ce n'est pas
possible et sa satisfait pas tout le
monde non non bah comme je vous l'ai dit
l'amendement d'Aurélien Pradier n'est
pas retenue et donc dans le camp
d'Aurélien Fradier évidemment on n'est
pas satisfait écoutez
on a toujours dit et on respecte en ça
la position du bureau politique de la
républicains on a un certain nombre au
sein du groupe les républicain à dire
nous voulons que des personnes qui ont
commencé tôt avant 21 ans qui sont dans
le dispositif carrière longue puisse
partir après 43 à nuité sans décote a
priori l'amendement qui est adopté en
CMP dit les personnes en carrière à
longue avant donc 21 ans peuvent partir
à 43 ans mais avec des cotes ce qui ne
correspond donc pas ce que nous avions
voté
un milliard deux vous allez dégrader un
milliard de mais franchement moi
j'insiste ça veut dire quand vous donnez
un agent anticipé que vous accordez une
durée de retraite plus longue faut que
ce soit quand même justifié quand même
moi j'aime mieux la durée de retraite
plus longue que l'on donne pas
anticipation à celui qui est usé vous
voyez celui qui fait un métier difficile
lui il doit partir avant parce que sinon
il bénéficiera pas toute sa retraite ça
correspond ces agents anticipés à une
usure donc on vous accorde de partir
avant pour vous ayez à Dieu et de
retraite à peu près équivalent parce que
votre espérance de vie est limité dans
le dispositif votre espérance de vie
elle va être limitée à 20 ans l'usure
elle est
arrivés à la gelée c'est là qu'il faut
la prendre c'est pour ça qu'il faut être
raisonnable en tout faut être
raisonnable un dernier mot parce que
Aurélien pradien n'a pas dit clairement
s'il allait voter ce texte et on ne sait
pas exactement combien de républicains
voteront le texte à l'Assemblée cet
après-midi est-ce que vous comprenez ce
qu'il ne vote pas mais tout à fait tout
à fait on a le droit sont assez
différemment on a le droit de vous faire
des contrôles de propositions mais même
quand on est derrière il faut assumer
des responsabilités moi je pense que
quand même on a des acquis qui doivent
motiver à un certain nombre de mes
collègues députés à voter ça mais après
chacun fait heureusement que chacun fait
il y a pas de penser unique dans nos
familles heureusement mais on a acquis
déjà sur les minimum de pension une
revalorisation c'est jamais suffisant je
suis d'accord on a acquis une prise en
compte de l'usioprofessionnelle c'est
jamais suffisant une prise en compte des
mères de famille et une prise en compte
effectivement de ceux qui gardent on a
rendu un système un peu moins
inégalitaire et on rentre quand même
dans l'équilibre parce que c'est une
réforme budgétaire faut rentrer dans
l'équilibre et on arrive à combler les
déficits et non pas les creuser donc je
pense que le travail qui a été fait à la
fois par le Sénat par l'Assemblée
nationale à travers tout cela mérite
d'être pris en compte et puis après à
chacun à chacun de prendre ses
responsabilités merci René passer Marie
merci beaucoup
d'être de nous parler de cette réforme
et de cette commission mixparitaire à
laquelle vous avez assisté merci d'avoir
été avec